today in our school matter series the
crisis in the country's rural classrooms
due to a shortage of teachers about one
in five US students attend rural schools
but those communities struggle to
recruit and retain their instructors in
Colorado
rural teachers are among the lowest paid
in any state across the nation our
national correspondent Jericka Duncan
recently traveled to a small town in
Colorado to see how they're tackling the
problem these aspiring teachers
undergrads from the University of
Colorado and Colorado Springs are taking
a road trip to Simla the ranching
community along Highway 24 is only about
50 miles away from the city but for some
Simla feels a world away steve wilson is
the superintendent of the Big Sandy
school district where 335 students from
grades pre-k through 12 learn under one
roof when you bring in prospective
teachers to your school what are they
telling you they need salary was a big
thing key thing and that gets brought up
every year at the state level also
there's just a whole bunch more being
dumped on educators than used to be as
not as respected as much it's just a
tougher profession than it used to be we
have 11 sick days 15 years ago Wilson
says there were about 30 candidates for
every job opening but in the last few
years some postings have attracted zero
applicants our high school principal she
happened to be at a restaurant and the
waitress said that she was trying to
become a teacher through an alternative
licensure program so you hired a
waitress yes who was working to become a
teacher yes but you helped expedite that
process yes on this day these teachers
in training visited some of the
classrooms including Holly Kane's
kindergarten class what do you see as
some of the the major problems facing
rural school districts affordable
housing is probably the number one you
know we do live farther out so the
prices of things are higher you know you
go to the grocery store in a small
community you're gonna pay a higher
price than you would out of King Soopers
the 26 year olds
she struggles to pay student loans and
make ends meet on her $35,000 a year
teaching salary to cut costs last year
she lived in this camper in a field
outside of school what kept you going
while you were living in that trailer
just coming to school every day and
seeing seeing the children and just
making bonds with them good we heard
from Holly who talked about living in a
trailer yes what is it say about how
difficult it is to work and make a
reasonable salary it's difficult it has
to be something you truly love Mary
Bauer loves the job so much she came
back in 2018 after leaving in 2013 to be
close to her husband and their home near
Denver it's about 90 miles away now
during the week
Bauer stays with her sister in Simla she
said I know someone who has cheap rent
by that I mean free so I stayed my
sister's for free
she returned to Big Sandy to teach
Spanish after the district failed to
find a qualified teacher so they lost
their Spanish teacher at the beginning
of the square and tried online and it
was pretty difficult for them a lot of
the kids had to go back and repeat the
year that they lost they were that far
behind they were that far behind
yeah but coaxing former teachers and
retirees back into the classroom is a
band-aid solution you're expecting
upwards of eight to ten teachers to
retire in the next five years what do
you do then yeah that's tough thing some
people some schools are in that boat
right now and I think we're
shortchanging our students Wilson hopes
that some of these college students
actually return here as teachers curious
how many of you would be interested in a
rural school or a school like this in
the future what changed your mind
everyone's kind of in it together and I
really like that aspect I went to a high
school where I graduated with 300 people
and to think that this school has 300
kids from preschool to twelfth grade
just like blows my mind because
everybody knows each other and just a
that you could like work in a school
with that kind of community that bond I
just I want to be a part of it for CBS
this morning
Jericka Duncan Simla Colorado that's a
beautiful thing yeah education is part
of the promise of this country public
education and programs like that are
helping teachers are so important they
catch a good teacher can change or
everything ever